puis 18h30 un bout de plage à 20 km de
royan
robert hossein réalisateur et chez
vedette johnny hallyday pascal rivaux
arrivent sur le lieu où ils vont tourner
pendant six semaines un nouveau film le
point de chute
les prises de vue auront lieu de nuit
pour l'instant hossein explique à johnny
hallyday
le personnage de voyous qu'il va devoir
jouer 20 heures dîner avec l'équipe une
nouvelle explication
avant cela la turquie se mêlent avoir
exercé dans l'action et sans suite je
l'aimé pas il dans le comment cela
continue je la regarde comme ce
qu'avance pas moi ça c'est bon 21h30 au
scène explique encore le taux du pull up
dans la pop soul à regarder même la
roche calmement c'est toujours soir à
regarder tu l'as dans la poche pour
aller la tête pour que j'ai le sourire
je veux parler du mans je pense que ce
film sera non seulement moi mon premier
vrai film
premier bon film et en fin de compte je
crois que lui n'y croit aussi beaucoup
l'autre jour il me disait encore je
crois que moi ce sera également mon
premier vrai film une heure du matin
hossein explique toujours
c'est l'histoire relève vos mégots dual
côté et je vais
c'est que c'est bien qu'elle finisse
dans la lumière à courir comme ça
trois heures du matin en turnover la vie
oh